rios 4 millions d'habitants 4 millions
de danseurs y compris les nourrissons
emmailloté qui font ce qu'ils peuvent
pour suivre le rythme du carnaval
une ville immense
qui se creuse pour mieux recevoir la mer
sous le haut patronage du pain de sucre
énorme construction géologique resté
sans emploi
une ville ouverte je veux dire ouverte
au soleil
qui est le véritable président de la
république brésilienne et qui comme
telle a ses entrées partout
les architectes depuis qu'ils l'ont
découvert c'est assez récent ne pense
plus qu'à j
et lui fournit à ses belles terrasses
pour griller toute la population
m
1 720 mètres d'altitude sur son
promontoire à flanc de sienne et
corcovado un christ de 37 mètres de haut
oeuvres de landowski
le même qui nous devons le statut de
sainte geneviève qui attend l'arrivée
des barbares sur un des ponts l'île
saint-louis
étend ses bras protecteurs dans un geste
d'apaisement
qui n'est pas toujours b
quand je disais tout à l'heure que le
pain de sucre ne faisais rien je me
trompais il est chargé de fournir aux
touristes une vue générale de
rio-de-janeiro
là où on entend dire dans toutes les
langues
c'est grandiose
quelques réticents trop cela simplement
magnifique
ensuite or naissant
en redescend toujours
de l'autre côté de la ville un continent
seize fois la france la moitié de
l'amérique du sud 8 millions 500 mille
kilomètres carrés en tout ce qui ne
reste pas à découvrir reste en grande
partie à exploiter quand je dis
exploiter je veux parler de
l'exploitation des terres celle des
hommes a commencé depuis longtemps
oui
mario larchitecture appris ces lignes
dans la mer
que l'on doit volontiers les façades
ressemble parfois à de grandes vagues
figé des ruisselets de mosaïques
serpente dans les roues
la courbe fait l'impossible pour
l'emporter sur la ligne droite et fuite
en dansant devant le regard
la plage de copacabana
on l'a vu on la reverra
adopté conformément aux instructions
d'einstein la courbure général de
l'univers avec la langueur vous lé tout
comme le centre des affaires qui se
permet quelques velud d'immobilière
d'inspiration probablement statistiques
sans parler bien sûr des passantes qui
ont l'ondulation instinctive et naturel
are you to dance
la mer la montagne les maisons
les couleurs
les 24 écoles de samba comme celle ci où
on apprend six jours de m'exprimer ainsi
à ce désossé de sa pesanteur
mais
et
et dans ce cas aussi les jouets à
balancier qui ont la propriété dit on de
chasser la colère et les humeurs noires
l'argent dans souci généralement avec
les mêmes personnes car il est fidèle en
amour
et ce ne sont pas les occasions qui
manquent de le faire valser
la couronne elle même de l'empereur
pedro deux exposés au palais de
petropolis ne se retient pas d'amorcer
un mouvement tournant sous leur garde
ses admirateurs
en
tout dans sarrio vous dis-je y compris
les saisons qui amène les baigneurs à la
plage autour de noël et les renvoie chez
eux l'été qui au dessous de l'équateur
est une espèce divers indulgent
oh
en
hewitt ou danse et la vague et le vent
des cheveux les enfants les
cerfs-volants du parasol aussi
et l'écumé la robe et si les spectateurs
du stade ne danse pas c'est parce qu'ils
y sont trop serrées du moins font-ils un
effort pour bang
le football a le football
sont belles et fantasque et sa
chorégraphie compliquer la voix leur la
danse idéal pour les deux cent mille
clients hebdomadaire du plus grand stade
du monde parmi lesquels on enregistre
une moyenne honorable de suffocation et
d'écrasement des jeux des joues
ne parviendra
m